welcome back to season four of the
stronger by science podcast
in today's episode we reflect on the
four-year anniversary of our monthly
research review called monthly
applications in strengthsport
also known as mass which greg and i
write alongside our co-authors dr mike
zordos and dr eric helms
now as we were recording the episode i
referred to it as our fifth anniversary
but it was later brought to my attention
that
as we are in our fifth year of mass it
is actually
our fourth anniversary or you could say
the first anniversary of
our third anniversary celebration so i
profusely apologize for spreading this
misinformation
uh it is indeed anniversary number four
to commemorate this big occasion we've
released a free best of mass issue
and we're also launching a big charity
sale from april 27th
through may 4th in today's episode we
also have research reviews about
testosterone boosters and barbell
velocity tracking technologies
along with a coach's corner segment
about sticking points some very shocking
information about eels
and much more as always thanks for
listening
and we hope you enjoy the show welcome
back to the stronger by science podcast
this is your host eric trexler today i'm
going to be joined by a special
temporary guest co-host his name is greg
knuckles
greg how are you doing i am doing well
how are you
i am doing well uh starting out with a
quick announcement here
obviously last episode was the first
episode of season four
we mentioned that we are working on
developing a diet app
and we got a lot of really good uh
feedback about that a lot of people are
really excited about that
so first of all thanks we we really
appreciate all the interest and
excitement related to that
uh that announcement uh we will be sure
to keep you posted as things progress
like i said in the last episode we're
still a ways off from actually bringing
it
to market and making it available but we
are working diligently and we will
absolutely keep you posted
in the meantime quick sellout segment
you know what to do go over to
bulksupplements.com
five percent discount that's huge
savings you type in
sbs pod all caps when you check out
for a five percent discount on all your
supplement needs
okay how about some good news greg got
any good news for me
yeah yeah let's do it uh so
i uh i came across an article uh
from thegoodnewsnetwork.org
nasa confirmation earth is safe from
asteroid for
100 years so there is an asteroid
called 99942
apophis apophis um
it was discovered in 2004 and uh
based on estimates of its size and its
trajectory
and you know general general newtonian
physics
uh there was a fear that it might
impact earth in 2068 uh
and you know it wouldn't be like a
destroy all life
type event uh it's not as big as the
dine
as the asteroid that likely wiped out
the dinosaurs
uh but it's a big one it's a little over
a thousand feet across
and uh yeah scientists discovered it and
they said oh there's
there is a non-trivial chance that this
might hit earth and cause some uh
pretty pretty intense damage in 2068.
anyway um it recently made another
near pass by earth and by near pass i
mean
you know still like 10 million miles
away but that's a near pass in
astrological terms and that allowed nasa
to study it more closely
uh get a better idea of its size and
mass so they could rerun their
calculations
and they have confirmed beyond
uh you know any any reasonable
doubt that it is not going to hit earth
and kill a lot of people in 2068
so as far as i can tell that is very
very good news
i feel like people are way less freaked
out about asteroids and they should be
two things worth being freaked out about
that i think
aren't on enough people's radar
asteroids and solar flares
but anyway this particular asteroid
which
uh scientists were quite concerned about
don't need to be concerned about this
particular one and that
is very good news we did it i mean how
many are floating out there
like a dozen two dozen millions
okay well yeah like the the thing about
asteroids
is there's a bunch of them and
they're hard to detect because you know
and unless they
are made of like particular minerals
that um
you know reflect light uh it's hard to
see them because they're generally not
big enough to have like a radiation
signature which
is generally how we pick up like stars
and planets and whatnot
uh they're generally not massive enough
to bend light around them enough to
to pick them up uh using like relativity
and so like dude there might be some
very very spooky asteroids out there
that could do some
some serious damage um
and my understanding is that based on
our current technological capacities
if like if one was
on a collision course with earth we
would not be able to
notice it quickly enough to intercept it
and keep it from
like wiping out all life on earth or at
least like
wiping out a major city or something um
so anyway that that is something that
astrophysicists
are are very invested in doing a better
job of
uh identifying asteroids and trying to
figure out ways to
you know pull off like an armageddon
scenario to keep them from
you know being able to [ __ ] us up too
bad uh but i i don't think we're there
yet
um see every time i learn about a new
asteroid that's probably not going to
kill us
it helps me sleep a little bit easier at
night
i think that's perfect for the good news
segment i think everybody's really
feeling great after hearing that uh i've
got some
i've got some light-hearted we do we
usually don't do good news segment to
give people
millions of new things to worry about
very literally but well
i didn't talk about solar flares either
yeah well
yeah we can save that for a different
good news segment when we really want to
get people excited
sure uh i've got a slightly more
light-hearted approach
to the good news segment uh a very happy
ending here so
unfortunately there's this
eight-year-old boy his sister
uh was choking uh that's not good news
but uh this eight-year-old boy saved his
sister's life
uh because he learned cpr from john cena
on a nickelodeon show that's awesome two
things first of all this is the
the natural consequence of getting
really jacked like this is the
trajectory we should all be aspiring to
in the fitness world get so jacked that
you become a great wrestler
be so charismatic there that you become
a great actor
and then all of a sudden you have the
opportunity to teach cpr to the masses
and save
who knows how many lives john cena has
saved at this point
by teaching at least one at least the
confidence interval ranges from one
to seven billion i would say it's
somewhere in there
so first of all that's cool good for you
john cena
very jacked very good at teaching cpr
apparently
and this just brought me a lot of joy
because
a little known fact i used to be
certified
to certify people in cpr what i'm an
absolute master
of the art of cpr yeah i used to certify
you know a couple dozen people a year
run my little cpr course
uh no longer in the business it was hard
to keep up with that it's a fast
changing industry and i just kind of had
to hang it up
but yeah as a former cpr instructor this
brought me a lot of a lot of joy
how often did staying alive by the
beegees get stuck in your head
uh constantly yeah there's two of them
right it was staying alive
and another one bites the dust yeah um
but i would always go stand alive oh for
sure in my mind you know it's
it's just too snappy you can't pass that
up
also uh i don't i don't know if you
could call this good news but
uh if you didn't watch the office when
it was on tv
dear listener find the office cold open
where they're uh doing like a cpr
instruction
it is probably a top three office cold
open it's so funny yeah
that is a good one um all right well
there's some good news for us what about
some
feats of strength yeah sure so i have uh
one two three four this week
uh starting off with probably the big
one uh
lasha whose last name i will not attempt
to pronounce
georgian weightlifter that's georgia the
country not the state
uh he recently snatched 222 kilograms or
489
pounds that is a new world record which
breaks
his old world record um and uh
he's so strong i i really
really really uh want him to
either go like 230 270 at the olympics
or
uh the kilograms that correspond with uh
500 snatch 600 clean and jerk i think
that would be
what 227 228 and uh
about 275 273 i think
um but he's putting up numbers that are
absolutely absurd
nothing looks hard for him which i mean
like
weightlifting doesn't look as hard as
powerlifting because you you have to
move things explosively but
boy does it look like he still has some
some strength in the tank uh so strong
and really really just have my fingers
crossed that he does something
absurd at the olympics moving on
to power lifting jaclyn cornwell
a female lifter squatted 570 pounds in
the 148 class in knee wraps
uh that breaks stacey burr's record in
the class that i i believe we also
talked about on the podcast
um i had not heard of jack
of jacqueline cornwell before uh it
seems like she's been making some
fairly quick progress uh the lift looked
great
looked like she had quite a bit more in
the tank too so
uh really really good stuff for her
mariana gasparian who we've absolutely
talked about in feats of strength before
uh a 132 pound weight class
female lifter uh recently squatted in
training
257 kilos or 506
pounds for a double uh that's two kilos
over her current world record
and she did it for a double and uh
i could i could very easily see her
squatting
over 600 pounds in her next meet um
at 132 which is
[Laughter]
just bad [ __ ] crazy uh she's so strong
and with that double like it looked like
she had a fair bit more in the tank as
well
uh so just absolutely insane [ __ ] from
her
uh and finally uh a deadlift from
nabil lalu sure i'm pronouncing that
wrong
but a french junior lifter
i think he's 21 years old uh deadlifted
uh 320 kilos or 705 pounds
in the uh he and this was in training
but he competes in the 66 kilo weight
class or 145 pounds
uh the current ipf world record in that
class
is 303 and a half kilos or 669
and a key difference between this lift
and some of the other training deadlifts
that we've talked about on the podcast
before
is uh he did it without straps so i mean
there's no reason to think that he's not
good for that on the platform
and you should really go check out that
lift uh
he is someone who looks like he was put
on this planet
to deadlift um lockout right at knee
height
just the way the good lord intended uh
it's
it's a thing of beauty yeah you were so
mad
because i was so mad he had a post where
he said like
when you're sumo dead lifting make sure
you keep your hips high and you're like
yeah i mean
that that would be great if i had long
arms but
here we are yeah no i uh so when i'm
pulling deadlifts for reps like you know
anything more than like a triple
i intentionally don't lock out the early
reps of a set
because my deadlift lockout is above
testicle height
and so if i lock out 10 straight
deadlifts like
my testicles are going to hurt after the
set so
there is an entire body body segments
difference between where his lockout is
which is
at the bottom of his femur and where
mine is which
may actually be above the top of my
femur i i don't know
i i don't think my uh i don't think my
arms actually reach my greater
trochanter when i'm standing
so uh yeah i am definitely envious of
his deadlift leverages
i mean it's crazy his his deadlift is
is truly something special but
you watch the video and he is locking
out at the top of the patella
yeah like it it is like you said
he is made to deadlift and boy is he
putting that to good use
for sure and he's still young too and it
looks like he could add
a ton of muscle to his frame oh yeah
like i mean i i could see him
i don't know if he moved up a one weight
class i
i think the next one's 74. i could see
him pulling over 800 in the 74 class
yeah yeah and he's getting so strong so
quickly too
like he's really ramping it up so i
don't think i'd feel comfortable
putting a cap on any estimate you know
like
like of what he could do at the next
weight class or the one after that
dude i don't know he's he's gonna do
what he wants to do with his deadlift
okay uh moving on to the next segment
uh every now and then we do an article
discussion if we like put out some
content
we want to talk through some of the
feedback or the reception
in this case we're going to do a
discussion about a mass
issue and it's a very spec special
mass issue because it is our
best of we put out a best of issue
every year right around anniversary time
so the mass five year anniversary is
coming up and along with that
is one of our big charity sales that we
do
so the nice thing about this issue we
went back through the last year of
issues and kind of picked out our
favorite articles this is going to be
accessible
to everybody it's not just for
subscribers i think
you get on the email list to get this
issue is that right yeah yeah
yeah so you can get on the email list
get this
special issue for free and like i said
it corresponds with our big charity sale
so from april 27th to may 4th
that's a tuesday through a tuesday
that's when our sale is running
uh i have no idea when this episode's
going to air but it's
we're going to get in before that sale
so this is relevant information
so yeah our sale prices are are
obviously lower than normal
and the really nice thing is we're
giving 100
of proceeds from new monthly
subscriptions uh but of course we also
have yearly and annual
subscriptions as well so for those we
give per subscriber
and all those proceeds go to the one
acre fund
uh and you picked out the charity for
this particular sale do you want to say
something about the one acre fund
yeah yeah absolutely so i really really
like the one acre fund
uh for a few reasons one i think
they're working to address um
a very real problem in the world that
often goes undiscussed
so a lot of a lot of people especially
in poor countries still
do subsistence agriculture like that's
one of the main ways that that people
and villages and towns are are able to
eat
um and that
so between a lot of factors like between
poverty
and droughts and famines and whatnot um
still like close to 10 million people
per year
die of hunger in the world like eight to
nine million people
uh and you know there's obviously no
silver bullet one size fits all uh
solution to that but one of the things
that can help
a lot is being able to shore up uh
small holder farms and so uh
one i think one acre fund is is tackling
a very real and important problem
and two i really really like the model
that they use
so uh basically the
there are issues with just like
delivering food to people in need like
obviously if there is like an acute
famine or drought or something
that's something that's absolutely
necessary but when there are food
shortages
in areas where there are also farmers
that can
that can actually hurt the farmers
because like now free food is flooding
the market it makes it harder for them
to sell their stuff
you know and so you can run into issues
there um
one of the other approaches to helping
out smallholder farmers
is basically just to give them
seeds give them equipment stuff like
that
and that's absolutely a great way to
address that problem but it's somewhat
financially inefficient
so you know basically if an organization
buys
five hundred dollars worth of seeds
distributes that to farmers
that's 500 out of their coffers uh so
what one acre fund does
is they basically make interest-free
loans to farmers
to buy seeds buy equipment uh
participate in training to like learn
new techniques to increase crop yields
etc
um and so one
they're not like saddling them with debt
that they're that it
something punitive is going to happen if
they can't pay it back but repayment
rates are really really high
like in excess of 95 and then also when
that money
comes back from the farmers that they
can pay back because they do increase
yields
then they can loan it out to more
farmers to
you know so it basically snowballs and
they can help
more and more people uh and the program
works like the
farmers increase crop yields it improves
their quality of life
one of the main things that these
farmers do when they
you know have more money coming in uh is
then
then they're able to send their kids to
school instead of
making them help on the farm um and it
not only increases the you know wealth
and income
of these small holder farmers uh but
there's trickle-down effects where it
can
improve the the wealth and functioning
of entire communities
so it's it's tackling a really really
important issue and i think it does it
in a particularly good way it is hands
down my favorite charity
uh i'm very very passionate about it
uh and so yeah i'm i'm very very happy
that we're able to support them awesome
and uh like i said uh monthly
subscriptions are on sale for 21.
if you sign up during the sale 100 of
those proceeds
go to the one acre fund we also have
yearly subscriptions for 209. these are
us dollars
we also have a lifetime subscription on
sale for 6.99
and if you're a current subscriber and
you want to upgrade to a lifetime
subscription that is discounted to 5.99
during the sale and if you do an annual
subscription or a lifetime during the
sale like i said
twenty one dollars per subscriber goes
to the one acre fund
uh okay so like i said the sale
corresponds to the five year anniversary
of mass which is pretty crazy it's uh
i think things really picked up around
year three if i had to
why why do you think that eric that was
right around the time i got involved
uh for some reason you
and helms and zordos thought you could
go it alone
uh which i thought was very ego driven
and very misguided but
uh but yeah fifth year of mass uh so the
50th issue i think
i went back and counted the 50th issue
comes out on may 1st and
with mass every issue has eight articles
and two videos per month
so by a quick tally we're talking about
approaching the 400 mark
for articles and 100 videos
in the archive and by the way if you do
subscribe you get access to the entire
archive not just
you know the stuff that comes up after
you subscribe
so man that's a lot of work
that's pretty crazy yeah it's going on
like five i think it's probably cleared
5 000 pages of content already
so you know if you subscribe it will
keep you busy
there's there's a lot of information in
there absolutely
and you know with mass like you know
you're an author
like i said helms and zordos and me uh
we like to to get into the nitty-gritty
research stuff but but we always try to
keep a focus on practical applications
so i think sometimes people hear about
a research review and they're like yeah
but you know i
i'm not really that into research i just
want to know how to use it you know i
want the
the application the conclusions and of
course we always try to highlight that
that's a main
focal point of what we do but you know i
think
one of the cool things about reading a
research review
is that you get some transferable skills
related to interpreting research that
you can apply
to whatever the hell you want you know
so a lot of times i'm sure you get this
all the time people will message me and
say
here's a study what do i do now you know
like i want to know what to do with this
but
nobody has reviewed it that i follow and
so i think it's really cool
what i always encourage people to do if
they do subscribe to mass is
if this is a skill set you want to
develop interpreting research
i encourage people to go through a study
on their own one that we're going to
review
in the issue and before they read our
review do your own review
and kind of compare your notes and i
think it can be a really helpful thing
that
you know without that key skill of
research interpretation
you know you're kind of at the mercy of
i hope someone i trust reviews this
article you know or
puts out content related to it but it's
it's really empowering when you can get
some of those skills
and apply it to other studies that that
maybe haven't been covered by some of
your favorite
uh people that you follow in fitness or
you can
take the approach i did which was uh
start reading research
put your interpretations out there in
the world and then have people a lot
smarter than you
say you're full of [ __ ] this is stupid
you missed
these very obvious things uh i mean that
that's
that was my basic process uh just
looking like a complete [ __ ] idiot
for like a year and a half two years
um and yeah i mean there's uh there are
better approaches to it than that
there are and like i said it's just uh
even if you you don't think like oh one
day i want to
you know get involved in research or
review research as a content creator or
something like that
just having a little bit of exposure to
the process can be such an empowering
thing because whenever a study comes out
that
that makes a lot of noise or something
comes out that's very relevant to your
needs
and you're like i need to know what to
make of this you can dive in and have a
really informed
process of trying to get to the root of
what's going on in that study
you know i think one of the biggest
additions in mass lately
something i know you're proud about you
you made a post about this on facebook
not too long ago but
within the past year in volume four
issue nine i think that's when we
introduced it
we call it the criticisms and
statistical musings
section and like i said we try to
always focus on practical application
but we're here to review the research
you know
we have to dig into it and this process
of being
you know fair but critical digging into
the statistical aspect of the study
uh which is very easy to overlook it's
always been part of the process but
now we've really formalized it as kind
of a stand-alone section
really a key pillar of of what we're
doing especially
if there's a study where maybe we don't
think the stats are particularly
up to snuff yeah um but yeah i mean i i
think that's probably one of the
coolest things we've done in the past
couple years is
including that section i think a lot of
people are stoked about it
no i i think so too and i think it uh
i think it adds a lot of value i think
the
first way it adds value is it
allows us to separate out the
statistics and data issues from the
actual application stuff so
one of the issues we at least in my
opinion
that we used to run into is that if
there were any
statistics or data issues um that we
noted in a study
we'd try to get through them quickly in
the interpretation section
because we're like okay like most people
are reading this for the practical
application stuff
probably don't want to bog people down
reading about statistics or
study design or anything like that for
multiple pages
so now that we've kind of isolated that
to it to a standalone section
um we can both devote more time and
energy to that to really getting into
the issues
and also since the interpretation
section is now
mostly opened up to specifically talking
about practical stuff and application
uh i think we feel a little bit more
freedom to get into that a bit more too
so i think that
it's both improved the quality of the
product and improved
the process of creating it
and yeah i think i think one of the big
benefits as well
is a lot of the studies that you see
people
discussing oftentimes like there is
stuff
about them that's just kind of like
flatly wrong
um that i just don't see anyone else
discussing so
uh an example of this that i
see brought up pretty frequently uh just
one example coming to mind
is there was a study from a couple years
ago uh that was looking
at the effect of full range of motion
versus partial range of motion on
triceps growth uh
and the partial range of motion was kind
of through the middle part of the range
of motion
instead of like just the top part of the
range of motion uh
and that study found that the partial
range of motion
actually uh in caused more triceps
growth than full range of motion which
uh is the first time that's been found
in the literature a lot of people talked
about it
um one of the things that i haven't seen
other people discuss
related to that study is the
actual amount of like tricep size
reported in the study is is literally
just not possible
um so like their subjects allegedly had
triceps that i think were i think they
said they were like 50 60 square
centimeters
which uh you know you can visualize that
for yourself
no one's triceps are that [ __ ] big um
and so like
who knows maybe they just used some sort
of formula
and they made some sort of error or
maybe they just mislabeled
some units for their graphs or something
like that uh
but yeah i mean that's that's a very
clear data issue
that uh people should dive into and
discuss and
like we did talk about that in mass but
i mean i've seen dozens of people talk
about that study and no one else brings
it up which
uh you know is it it doesn't like
completely invalidate the study there
are
there is probably a very innocent
explanation for it but
you know that's something that readers
and consumers of information should be
made aware of and i i don't see other
people
making their readers aware of it and
that stuff like that happens all the
time
and we get into it in mass and it's not
that no one else does but i
don't see it being done nearly
frequently enough
yeah i mean my personal experience with
that was
i got on a a streak of reviewing
meta analyses and i know i've mentioned
it
on the podcast before at least certain
aspects of it but i think i did
five meta-analyses over a stretch of
time
and three of them were wrong enough
that the conclusions were completely
incorrect so like saying that x does
y and like the actual conclusion should
have been x does not do y
or vice versa i mean it's not just like
oh you know you forgot a decimal point
there and you know you got to go edit
that
it was just like this is fundamentally
not a true thing uh because of
very identifiable errors and uh and yeah
it's
you'll see people talking about the
study and like ah
not only do we have a study saying this
is true we have a meta-analysis of all
things and it's like yeah but
it's like very wrong you know yeah so i
i think that's
seeing that play out enough times is
kind of what i
i think led to us saying we got to
include this and just kind of
make it its own section so people can
kind of venture into it
at their own risk but you know it's
really important and so we can just
tell people very explicitly what sorts
of things to watch out for
yeah yeah because it's not like these
are
so rare that you'll never encounter the
same thing again
yeah it's very rare that one of the
things we talk about in that section
it's like oh here's here's a brand new
way that someone
messed up their stats it's like oh no
this this person made the same error
that we've seen
30 other [ __ ] people make before
so anyway just be aware of that here is
the issue
when you read research for yourself you
will come across people making this
mistake all the time
uh here's what it is here's how to
recognize it etc
yeah and i think one of the really
unfortunate things when people start
reading research
is that they can develop this kind of
apathy
you know because without a really decent
grasp on
the statistical components and the
common errors to look out for
statistically
you get into this apathetic mindset
where you're like listen i can't see the
raw data it's usually not available
i kind of just have to take the
researcher's word for it i don't know
how to fact
check the statistics here i don't know
where to even begin or what to look for
and i think i would like to think that
we're helping
alleviate that apathy for a lot of
people because
i think the things we like to do is look
at these statistical results
like a puzzle in a lot of cases you can
back
calculate things to really fact check
the analysis itself and sometimes we do
that
in this particular section another thing
we're fond of
is you see some numbers that look weird
and you're like okay so you're telling
me the mean is this and the standard
deviation is this
and we just simulate data and say like
well what does that
look like and we can simulate it a few
times and get a feel for like
if those numbers are true what what
would this look like in a spreadsheet
uh and we can use that to kind of fact
check and get a feel for some of these
things and sometimes
we even extract the data points from a
study and just run the analyses
differently
we say like you know there's individual
figures here we can digitally extract
the data
analyze it in a way we feel is more
appropriate and then
interpret both of those you know in the
interest of transparency so
i would like to think that this section
even if you're not like
really enthusiastic about statistics i
would like to think that some mass
readers have begrudgingly
found it to be quite helpful and
informative
no i i hope so i think it's really fun
because it's
um did you ever do those like logic
puzzles back in the day like you know
uh joe is four years older than susie
and uh you know tim has a brown stick
and is twice as old as sal whatever yeah
and you're just trying to figure out
like all of you should be able to deduce
things about all of the people i i kind
of view
uh i kind of view this process the same
way like
you can look at what is reported in a
study and you're like ooh
based on what's here i know everything
that i can figure out
from this data let's figure it out and
see how well that actually comports with
the reported results
yeah and like sometimes you just find
stuff that's literally impossible
like one of the things that i enjoy
doing the most
uh is granularity testing results yeah
so
especially in small sample research so
here's a very simple example
um if there's
you know let's say there's a study it's
testing strength
measure to the nearest kilo and there's
eight subjects per group
based on that information you should
know
every possible group mean uh based on
the
decimal result on the back of it so
eighths will either be
uh if they've reported it to three
decimal places something
0.125 0.25 0.375
0.5 0.625 0.75 0.875
or 0.0 those are the only possibilities
because when you divide a whole number
by eight
those are the decimal possibilities so
if you see something where they say
there's eight subjects per group
and they're measuring strength to the
nearest kilo and they report
uh an average squat 1rm of like
122.17
then like the chase is a foot cause you
know don't know what they did
but something here doesn't add up and
it's i i think it's fun to then
dive in and try to figure out what's
happening yeah no it is really fun
because
like i said it's it's these are puzzle
pieces and they
if they don't fit together there's
something wrong with the puzzle
you know what i mean uh we actually had
when i was uh
in school we had a class that was just
kind of dedicated to doing those
different logic puzzles
and at the time i thought it was so
stupid and then now that i'm older i'm
like that was probably the most
useful class i took but
kids don't know anything you know i
thought it was such a waste of time
um so looking through i'm looking at the
table of contents for this best of issue
and uh there's some good stuff in here
uh
you've got an article about
individualizing training volume you've
got one about
uh ribosome biogenesis and how that
relates to uh
volume and muscle growth you've got one
about uh
sex differences uh with regards to
fatigue
during during lifting uh man there's a
lot of good stuff in here
i i've got uh an article that i've
mentioned on the podcast talking about
glycogen depletion during lifting
a huge myth that we like
the glycogen depletion that occurs
during lifting is completely
physiologically inconsequential and it's
not just like one of those myths where
you're like where the hell did this come
from
i think this particular study was one of
the things that made it really great was
that
it showed us methodologically why that
was wrong
and a more nuanced way to to look at
glycogen depletion during lifting so i
thought that was a fantastic study
and then always updating the literature
on protein so
i had an article in here about protein
distribution looking at
the right amount of leucine and amino
acids and total protein per meal
how to spread that throughout the day to
maximize hypertrophy so
uh and that's just our articles you know
there's a bunch of great stuff in here
by
by zordos and helms talking about stuff
like uh
how close to failure you need to train
in order to maximize your gains
helms has a progression framework for
hypertrophy kind of how to
you know progress your training week
over week micro cycle in a micro cycle
in order to support
hypertrophy we've got an article on the
interference effect which is
always a crowd favorite we get so many
questions about the interference effect
and then some videos as well so
zordos has one about volume cycling
which is a really a really popular idea
in the lifting world the idea of kind of
ramping up your volume but then
dropping it back down and ramping up
again and then helms
with a video on translating nutrition
guidelines to real life
you know we can put out these uh you
know these documents that have like a
million numbers in there about how to
put
a diet together but ultimately if you're
trying to help somebody with their
nutrition goals
you got to make it relatable you got to
actually turn that into real life
recommendations so uh this is a very
complete issue now that i look back at
it
this is good stuff so if you're
interested in
digging into that issue i would
absolutely encourage you to do so like i
said just uh
get on the the email list i'll put the
link to that in the the show notes for
today's episode
and it'll be yours uh all right so
greg i understand that you've got a
brief research roundup is that correct
yeah you know what i put it in the
research roundup
segment of uh of the outline it's more
just a brief research review
i i i didn't i didn't want to call you
out for that yeah no it did violate
the spirit of the roundup segment i
violate the spirit of the [ __ ] good
news segment every single episode
yeah we really when we set out to do
this we had two guiding principles first
we're following in the footsteps
bill o'reilly and rush limbaugh that was
the first part
the second part was it's a segment show
you got to honor the segments
you have to respect what the segments
stand for and stay within the
constraints
i i suppose this is why i am still only
a temporary guest co-host
absolutely yeah so this is more
of like a consumer psa than anything
else i suppose
um so uh velocity-based training
has been getting more and more popular
in recent years
and with that in mind a very
uh a very prominent consideration
is okay so what what device are you
going to use to
track and measure velocity like
obviously if you're trying to use
lift velocity as a data point to you
know
factor into load selection or when to
terminate sets like proximity to failure
type stuff
assessing how much fatigue you've
accumulated between sets throughout a
workout
uh ideally you want your velocity
measurements to be
accurate and reliable um
and so there are three basic types of
products on the market that you can use
to
ascertain your velocity um there are
linear position transducers which
are uh the ones where there's basically
a little string that goes around
the bar and there's a like a
an electronic unit generally that
connects to an app via bluetooth
and it's just straight up measuring how
quickly
the the string is spooling and
unspooling uh
it's a very simple technology but it
works really well
so those are called linear position
transducers uh
tindo was was i think the first one on
the market certainly the first really
popular one
uh gym awares out there the open barbell
system is out there
um let's see uh speed for lifts now
called vitruv
is out there that's another linear
position transducer and
they're all good linear position
transducers are
what is typically used in research if
they don't have
access to to the gold standard so the
the criterion measurement for that is is
basically if you have
uh like a like a [ __ ] forty five
thousand 000
12 camera system and you can put little
markers and and do like frame by frame
analysis at like 60 frames per second
that that's the gold standard um for
for motion tracking and ascertaining
lift velocity
uh you know that's that's not feasible
for
anyone outside of a research context
after that linear position transducers
are the next best but
uh linear position transducers tend to
be kind of pricey
uh so i i mentioned open barbell i think
it goes for like 250 300 bucks
uh i think vitruv is similar like maybe
three four hundred bucks
uh tindo and um
uh gym aware they're both 15 to 2 500
bucks
very very pricey uh the other two
types of products that you'll typically
find
are um accelerometer based products
so they're things so that there's one i
think
god i forget what it's called the push
band yeah there's the push band
um which i think you wear around your
wrist and and basically it measures
acceleration as you say stand up or go
down or in the case of a bench press as
you lower your arm and press it back
up there's one called the beast sensor
which is
magnetic and you can just like stick it
to the plates and same thing it measures
acceleration
i am not reviewing any studies in in
this podcast episode talking about the
accelerometry based
systems uh but they're not great they're
they're cheaper
um than than the linear position
transducers for the most part
uh but they they have more issues
they're not as accurate they're not as
reliable
but then the third option the most
consumer grade of them all
the very cheapest are apps so
uh basically using the visual processing
capabilities of your phone camera
to track a barbell through space
and uh you know measure and report
velocity and range of motion using that
and so you know you can you can go from
linear position transducers which are
you know between 250 and like 2 500
bucks
to accelerometry based products which
really aren't that much cheaper than the
cheapest linear position transducers i
don't think anyone should
ever use them but whatever uh but yeah
they're i think around 150 bucks for the
most part
uh to these apps so i think the most
popular one is called iron path
and i do think you have to pay for it
but i think it's like five bucks or
something um
so you know that makes it a really
really attractive option for most people
but the question is is it good does it
work
ideally it does uh but in practice it
does not
so the the title really took the took
the suspense out of it yeah i did
uh but that's fine so the the title of
the paper
uh that i that i'm looking at
specifically is
agreement between the iron path app and
a linear position
transducer for measuring average
concentric velocity and range of motion
of barbell exercises by kasovich
or kasovic at all came out earlier this
year
and so um it was comparing the iron path
app
to a previously validated velocity
system that is the open barbell system
which again is a linear position
position transducer
and this was a very well done uh
essentially validation study so
basically looking to see
does the iron path app produce results
that are similar enough to the open
barbell system
to be useful to people um
and so one of so
a lot of validation studies you know
in exercise science unfortunately aren't
done well
um ultimately what a lot of validation
studies do is look to see
on average uh you know in the case of a
velocity device
is the average velocity reported by
device a
similar enough to the average velocity
reported by device b with one of them
being considered
the the criterion you're measuring
against so if those two aren't
significantly different or
are at least like nominally close enough
it's like okay that's pretty good
i like to see that and then the other
thing they'll do is just report
associations
so you know lift to lift um
how strongly correlated are
uh velocity numbers from one device
versus the other
and generally you know if you see a r
value of 0.8 plus you're like okay like
this is working pretty well i like it um
but ultimately that doesn't give you
that much information
ideally you want to be able to see kind
of lift by lift
uh numbers and to see how
badly things can go wrong um on the
individual level
yeah yeah on a rep by rep basis yeah and
so the
two sorts of charts you would use to
to represent and show that are mountain
plots
uh and bland altman plots so th
this article has both and on a bland
altman plot
something that is of great use is
limits of agreement so that that
basically shows
uh 95 of the time
where will the difference between two
measurements fall
uh and so you know ideally you won't
tight
limits of agreement on a bland altman
plot between the criterion device
and the new device you're testing
against it so for example
you know if you see that the bland
altman plot is
centered at zero that's good that means
on average there's no difference between
the two
and if the limits of agreement are say
plus or minus
0.05 meters per second that would mean
that 95
of the time this other device is giving
you
velocity measures within 0.05 meters per
second of
uh the criterion device which would be
really really good
and it's not biased in either direction
it could be you know within plus 0.05 or
within minus
correct yeah if it's centered at zero
yeah um so that that's
the type of thing you would want to see
for the iron path app in comparison to
the open barbell system the
limits of agreement were like plus or
minus 0.15 to 0.2
which is bad yeah in other words if
the open barbell system would say that
you lifted
a load at i don't know 0.5 meters per
second
uh the iron path app might say you were
going as fast as
0.7 meters per second which is fast or
0.3 meters per second which is
really [ __ ] slow um and so just to
put that in practical terms like what
0.15.2 meters per second means
uh that could be the difference of like
ten to twenty percent of one rm
so you know ninety percent of your max
in a squat maybe you can move that at
point four meters per second point six
meters per second that's probably around
70 75 percent um
or you know if you're using velocity to
quantify
proximity to failure 0.15.2 meters per
second that's like
three or four reps worth of proximity to
failure so
really it's yeah oh no i mean
it varies lift to lift so you lose more
velocity per rep as you approach failure
say on the squat than for the bench
press
yeah so it's going to vary lift to lift
um
yeah i mean you you could be at one rep
in reserve
uh or like a velocity that would
correspond to one rep in reserve and it
might be telling you that you're lifting
at a velocity that would correspond to
like five reps in reserve
uh like four or five which so that
that's not good like the the reason
people use
velocity to monitor training is you know
often times they're trying to use it to
uh determine what loads to train at so
for
load selection and intensity
determination or for
determining proximity to failure and
when you're dealing with limits of
agreement
in the 0.15 to 0.2 meters per second
range
it is not it can't do that
it's not good it's not good enough for
the data it's giving you to be
worthwhile like even if you're really
really bad at using
reps and reserve based rpe i would
almost guarantee
that that is still more accurate than
the iron path app yeah and i was going
to say that
the main reason people go this route
is because they want to take things up a
notch
with their precision you know they're
like know reps in reserve is fine but i
want to know the speed of the bar
you know i want to get even more precise
and uh
so that that's not uh that's not a great
stamp of approval with those
limits of agreement no so yeah if you
want to get into velocity-based training
um
[Music]
find a linear position transducer it's
really the way to go
like i said the the accelerometry based
ones are
it seems better than the iron path app
but really not that much
better like they're still not great uh
and
of all of the linear position
transducers
i think the ones that have
the most support backing them up is
there was uh one study
from maybe like two or three years ago
that was comparing like eight devices
all head-to-head against each other and
at that point
uh the one that did the best was one
called speed for lifts which is recently
rebranded to vitruv
um so there there's some some good data
backing that up
and then the one most often used in
research is
uh ah [ __ ]
i always forget it it's the one i used
in my [ __ ] thesis project
do you use gym aware yeah gem aware uh
gym aware
is is probably the one with the most
research on it
and gym wear is also really cool because
there's a little
laser sensor as well to not just look at
how much of the the string has unspooled
to
measure total velocity but it's also
looking at the
angle that the string is moving in so
you can get an idea of bar path as well
um so yeah it's it's really good as well
those would be the two products i'd
recommend both for a
more expensive and a cheaper linear
position transducer
uh really i i just would not recommend
either a phone app or an accelerometry
based one i just don't think they're
good enough
to be used for the things people
generally would want to use velocity for
and of course this goes without saying
but i always like to clarify whenever we
say like hey you got to go with
one of these more expensive options
there's a lot of very effective ways to
train
without measuring your velocities oh for
sure yeah if you want to go that route
exactly yeah these are by no means a
mandatory prerequisite for getting into
the gym
and making great progress but yeah yeah
if you want to get into velocity-based
training i
i really do think you need to make the
plunge and
and shell out some money for a good
device the the the cheap ones on the
market
and this pains me to say because i'm the
guy that likes the cheapest version of
[ __ ] everything
um not with clothes you're a george guy
the george brand i mean that's top level
stuff uh
i i buy myself some george when i'm when
i'm feeling fancy
yeah uh i think most of my i think the
median price of the shirts i own is like
4.95 nice um but yeah yeah so
i would love for the cheapest option to
be the best one or at least to be
good enough but in the case of being
able to monitor bar speed
that's unfortunately just not the case
uh the the linear position transducers
really really
are the way to go all right good stuff
i've got a brief research review here
uh i don't know why i mean this is one
of those classes of supplements i
figured i should probably address at
some point
just because there's always so much
interest in these supplements so many
questions about them
so i wanted to briefly talk about
testosterone boosters as a category of
supplements
and you know this is a body of
literature that
if you are very impatient
and you want a very clear answer now
this body of literature is going to
drive you nuts
it will be immensely frustrating but
if you're just kind of along for the
ride and passively viewing this body of
literature it's just quirky
it's just kind of funny so i would
encourage you to adopt the latter
perspective and just kind of
hang on for the ride here because it is
a
very strange body of literature uh
especially when it comes to how the
literature is applied
when you see the claims on the
supplement labels you're thinking wow
there must be some very robust evidence
floating around out there
and that's not necessarily the case
before i get into the details i do want
to give a brief shout out to examine.com
because what you find in the
testosterone booster literature
is a lot of herbal ingredients that have
been studied like twice
in humans or less and so whenever i come
across some new herbal ingredient
you know one of the first things i do is
i say has examined talked about this
you know because they do a very nice job
giving a
kind of a rundown of what we know about
this
huge number of supplements out there you
know i mean
back in the day when i was real young i
worked at a vitamin shop
it's amazing the number of supplements
that are on the market
you know all these things that you've
just never even heard of so
examine.com is a great one-stop shop for
you hear about some random herb and
somebody says it increases your
testosterone 40
you might want to look it up and see
what's going on so
let's set the stage for the problem here
uh so in men testosterone levels
generally tend to peak around age 20
give or take
and when we when men start getting into
their 30s and beyond it starts to
decrease
on average by like one or two percent
per year
so more than a third of men over the age
45
may have lower than normal testosterone
levels and more than
half of men over 65 may have lower than
normal testosterone levels
now the reference range for testosterone
there there's a lot of different
estimates out there there's not like a
singular reference range that everybody
uses
uh but it's generally around 300
to nanograms per deciliter
which is uh three to 11 nanograms per
milliliter
uh which is around 10.5 to 38
nanomoles per liter uh greg you know
i've recently started
uh reading a lot about buddhism and uh
listening to a lot of podcasts about
buddhism and i've become really good at
regulating my emotions and just watching
them float by
as if in a river just objects passing by
not succumbing to those emotions not
engaging with them
yeah that's a real low t beta move not
letting them
commandeer my mind and you know
but i tell you what man when it comes to
units and studies
oh yeah yeah all of that goes out i put
my
fist through the screen of my computer
whenever i do this endocrine research
and i'm looking up all these papers and
it's like
i'll look up seven papers and there are
six different units being used i'm like
how is this even possible
yeah uh so testosterone luckily you're
only going to find
generally those three so i could be
wrong but i think that
i think that america ruins a lot of that
i think
i'm certain we do i think in like the eu
and most of the rest of the world
they do it in like
magnitudes of moles per liter so
you know moles per liter nanomoles per
liter
moles per liter etc and like
we we still use metric you know so we're
not gonna we're not gonna say
like 0.017 ounces per
tablespoon or something uh so we
that's a disaster so we we still use
metric units but like
very non-standard metric units which
is just [ __ ] bonkers to me like if
we're gonna go metric
ju just go with what the rest of the
world that uses metric does
yeah it's it's really bad it can be very
frustrating
um yeah units in a lot of this endocrine
research
literally drives me nuts but but those
are the three
that you are most likely to see there
um so so that's kind of setting the
stage we've got our bearings on the
units i am going to refer
to specifically male testosterone levels
in this segment because that's where
pretty much all the research is
is specifically on male subjects for a
lot of these
and i'm going to try whenever possible
to use that first
scale so talking in nanograms per
deciliter
so again the reference range usually is
from like 300
to 1100 and an average value for a young
healthy man
is usually about 600 but of course
there's a lot of
wiggle room around 600 there
so talking testosterone boosting
supplements
people in the fitness world when we talk
testosterone
we're thinking performance and body
composition but
you know the symptoms of low
testosterone are
all over the place someone with you know
clinically low testosterone
might experience swelling or tenderness
of breast tissue
irritability depression difficulty
concentrating loss of body hair hot
flashes low libido
erectile dysfunction and just kind of
feeling tired all the time fatigue
and so there's a lot of different
reasons why a researcher
might look into some type of
non-pharmaceutical remedy for low
testosterone so
i think that's kind of the first thing
to remember with this body of literature
is
you go hey where's all the bench
pressing well most of the people
studying this don't care about bench
pressing they're
you know looking at things related to
fertility
in men who have you know some degree of
infertility like that that's where a lot
of this research exists
so when we talk through which of these
ingredients might actually work to some
extent
uh you know we want to talk about
practical significance and in order to
do that we have to figure out
you know what what is the reason for
pursuing a test booster like what is the
outcome that we're gonna focus on here
uh and so based on the context of the
podcast
i'm gonna assume that we're talking
about test boosters here for body comp
and performance uh
i don't want to suggest that that's the
only reason someone might
seek uh some type of testosterone
intervention but
that's what we're going to focus on
because you know stronger by science
that
that's the name uh so there's
a lot of different ingredients out there
uh
that have been researched i'm gonna
highlight the biggest ones that you're
probably
most likely to maybe get talked into
trying
because they're the most popular you
know if you walk into a supplement store
it might be the one that somebody tries
to sell you on so
i'm gonna get into a little bit of
detail about uh about a couple of big
ones but then just kind of address
the uh the other ones there's kind of a
enormous and ever expanding list of
things that people
say might influence your testosterone
levels but
the first one that that really got big
in the lifting world
uh not chronologically first but the
first one that i'm covering
is d-aspartic acid or daa
and the first human trial to my
knowledge was published in 2009
and it showed this big increase in
testosterone production i believe it was
42 percent
um and so people saw that and they're
like damn
this stuff is pretty wild 42 increase in
testosterone
i could use some of that uh
but the rest of the research following
that didn't really reinforce those
impressive findings and in fact
you know most of the studies that
followed it's not like there were a ton
but a few trickled out
and they pretty much didn't show much at
all and then in 2015 a study came out
that actually
indicated that d-aspartic acid decreased
testosterone levels
in resistance-trained men uh i don't
think it was to a practically relevant
degree but certainly uh
not a 42 percent increase so overall d
aspartic acid it kind of developed a
great reputation because of this
big first paper that made a splash uh
and when that happens it can be really
hard to
to walk that back once something gets
out there with these really promising
findings uh
it develops your reputation that can be
hard to lose
uh but but there's really no consistent
effect shown
in this overall body of literature when
it comes to
testosterone there are you know
most of the findings that are promising
are in people with low testosterone but
even in those people the if the effects
are not super consistent
and there's actually there's some
evidence to suggest that
even if testosterone is elevated by
d-aspartic acid supplementation it may
just drop back down to normal after like
a week and a half or so
which kind of makes sense when you think
about how testosterone works
uh you know we've got this axis this
endocrine hormone
cascade uh that starts with the
hypothalamus it goes to the anterior
pituitary then it goes to the testes
so we've got this series of hormones
getting released all the way from the
hypothalamus down to the testes
and there are multiple areas where
negative feedback can occur
so the amount of testosterone in your
blood is sensed by the body
and that influences all the hormones
higher up on the cascade and it keeps
testosterone at a normal level these
things are
controlled within you know what your
body thinks is supposed to be
kind of the normal range and so uh you
know a very
obvious example of this is when people
go on
really high dose and exogenous
testosterone
their endogenous production decreases
substantially
and that's because you know these higher
centers the hypothalamus the anterior
pituitary
they are getting a clear message hey
there is not only enough testosterone
we're like three times where we used to
be like
there's a lot of testosterone and so the
hypothalamus the anterior pituitary they
say okay that well that's fine
certainly you don't need any
gonadotropin releasing hormone then
and so the system generally tries to
regulate itself within a kind of a
normal working range
and so that's why i'm not particularly
surprised that even if you did find a
supplement that
maybe got you a little bit of extra
i wouldn't be stunned to expect that it
would kind of just regulate its way back
down toward a normal range
but we're going to talk a little bit
about the magnitude of increase
later before we get to that i want to
move on to the second big one that
you're likely to see
and that's tribulus terrestris uh
and this is i would say the most popular
one out there uh th this is kind of the
og
uh as f as far the first test boosters i
ever became aware of
were almost all tribulus centered
and there was a great review paper
actually in 2019 by santos
and colleagues and it was called beyond
tribulus
the effects of uh phytotherapeutics on
testosterone sperm and prostate
parameters
and so the entire premise of this paper
was just like forget tribulus
like we're done with tribulus let's move
past tribulus because
uh within uh within this review they
pretty much acknowledge they pretty much
acknowledge that
there's been plenty of work on tribulus
uh of course like any other supplement
there is a couple little
glimpses that might have been promising
early on but
generally speaking you look at the
tribulus literature whether you're
trying to
increase testosterone enhance
performance enhance body composition
when we're looking at people that are
otherwise healthy
it's just really a non-starter and
there's a systematic review
by quereshi and colleagues in 2014
that directly look at looked at tribulus
intake
its effects on free and total
testosterone within a
wide range of dosing parameters with
trials lasting four to eight weeks
there's just not much there to get
excited about you look like you're about
to
say something yeah i've got a question
about these
so-called fake news systematic reviews
okay did they potentially look at
the geographic component of the
effects of tribulus uh they actually did
not
interesting so i i'm on uh
an alternate science website uh
biotest supplement store okay uh they
have a product called alpha male
and they they note that they have
bulgarian
tribulus ah so let's let's read a little
bit of this research
tribulus acts as a luteinizing hormone
secretog
in other words it causes the release of
luteinizing hormone which in turn
signals the testes to produce more
testosterone
and all of the t-boosting compounds and
of all the tea boosting compounds on the
market
tribulus is the most powerful so that
that's the first thing that that review
got wrong
uh there are many t-boosting compounds
on the market and tribulus
is in fact the most powerful of them all
uh
okay so it goes on the brutal reality is
most tribulus products on the market are
either completely inactive or
inferior herbal substitutes that are
mistakenly
spiked with proto-dyson either way
you get the same result nothing you
can't simply take
chinese or indian or quote-unquote
german
plant material i don't know why they put
german and scare quotes there
uh i don't know regardless you can't
take uh
chinese indian or german plant material
and spike it with proto-dyson
to make real testosterone boosting
tribulus it's a cheap and ineffective
imitation
and it's dishonest and if i know one
thing about biotest
they care deeply about honesty
genuine full-spectrum tribulus that
boosts testosterone
is only found in bulgaria
and contains many powerful compounds
vital for producing
ideal results all compounds have to be
present in quote-unquote fingerprinted
full-spectrum ratios to achieve the
maximum effect
biotest tribulus contains the most
potent full-spectrum
extraction of real bulgarian tribulus
each of the active compounds is present
in the required amounts
for maximum performance and now you may
ask what sources did they cite for any
of that
i would uh respond with saying wait you
have the source right here
uh i was gonna ask if they then followed
that up with the
randomized controlled trial they funded
to no
no absolutely not and here's the funny
thing uh
they have some uh uracoma
long folia or uh long jack
in the supplement as well and some for
scolin
as well and they do they do actually
have a
references list at the bottom of their
sales page
and they they have the they have
reference lists for
long jack and forskolin but absolutely
nothing
for uh for their tribulus which
i think is incredible i i love their
sales copy so much it's
it's my favorite thing in the fitness
industry yeah i mean see i had
i hesitate to give a full belly laugh to
it because it could be one of those
things where there's a grain of truth to
it yeah
um so i'll i'll have to read up more
uh on the different subtypes of tribulus
but
i i can tell you the thing is if that is
a thing that exists
and you're already going to have a
reference list at the bottom of the page
you'd like to see a reference cite
something you know yeah yeah
i mean at least like a [ __ ] rodent
study or like some some in vitro [ __ ]
like throw me a bone there about
something yeah
but i mean who just based on the
literature that exists with
tribulus in general i do not have high
hopes i i can certainly say that with a
great deal of confidence
what does it tell you about other
testosterone boosting supplements if
they're calling that one
like the best and most validated of them
all
well it's not it's not a promising
outlook
uh i'll say that all right you can
continue with uh
the mainline science now that i have you
know
made sure that we're teaching the
controversy on this podcast no
see this is where we get into trouble so
we
you you got in a big internet fight not
too long ago
[Laughter]
about being sarcastic on the podcast
and no amount of sarcasm is thick enough
to avoid the dreaded one-star review
but more importantly we we do have to
keep our sarcasm to non-fitness
topics so i i'm officially
calling you out for being sarcastic
about bulgarian tribulus
if you're listening don't say that we
lost all our credibility because of greg
reading stupid sales copy no but my
favorite thing
about uh about that argument in my
instagram comments
is uh this guy was like yeah
obviously you don't know how to make
your sarcasm
uh obvious enough like based on the
the review that this person posted
you're not to be taken
seriously and like since i'm the one and
this was related to
uh to our our goofs and gabs about
marijuana by the way uh
and i just assumed that it was probably
someone leaving a one-star review about
something i said because most of the
one-star reviews are about
uh things that i've said anyway i went
back and listened to the episode and it
was actually [ __ ] that you said it was
me
uh so anyway i i
wasted way too much of my time uh
engaging with that person about
something i didn't even [ __ ] say
yeah it was like a 60 comment sub thread
it was really instagram
it was really fun though i i had a blast
yeah well
so his whole point was like if you're
gonna do uh
sarcasm it has to be outlandish enough
as to not be taken seriously you know
you have to go for it if you're going to
go for it
i proposed a literal policy in which the
state of oregon
would require legally require citizens
to use recreational drugs
against their will and you you made the
statement
there are no values there are no
families yes
what does that even mean there are no
families
it doesn't there's no meaning to this
yeah so yeah
anyway if if we're ever sarcastic about
actual
content i i think we do need to put a
little disclaimer
so uh there it is moving on
uh so anyway in this review they
basically said like yeah uh
tribulus it's a lost cause but let's
move on
and talk about some other stuff and they
talked about a whole bunch of other
stuff
but but the list is is pretty endless i
mean
if you look at the broader literature
and say like what are people
uh claiming as you know something that
can increase testosterone
uh it's you know zma fenugreek
dhea long jack maca
mucuna ashwagandha black seeds
boron i mean it is an extensive list of
stuff
and i i think the authors of this review
were
were quite charitable um because like
there's a lot of
bodies of research here where there's
just like a
study or like maybe two studies and it
looks like maybe there might be
something there that's worth following
up on but
i can save listeners a lot of time and
tell you
i i've looked into it i have yet to find
a single dietary supplement
that has robust evidence indicating that
it can increase testosterone
to a practically meaningful degree
reliably in healthy people
you might be able to look at some of
these bodies of evidence and say for
someone with low tests
you know struggling with infertility
there might be some reason to
try to use one of these supplements
under the direction
of a doctor who's treating you for your
infertility issue
um but but yeah i mean this
the idea that someone is like hey i want
to get big and strong
which test booster should i take there
is not robust evidence out there that
i've seen
to support literally any of them so
hopefully it saves you a little bit of
time now if you're listening and you're
like no i think there's one that eric's
missing he's overlooked it
he just you know it's a blind spot i'm
of course always open to the possibility
that i've got blind spots because the
worst part about him
is you can't see him so by all means you
know send me the name
send me some papers i'd be happy to
review and update on the podcast but
you know as i look through these review
papers as i look through the
the papers that they cite i'm just not
seeing the evidence
to suggest that there is any really good
non-steroidal test booster out there on
the market today that's going to be
worth your while
i even i covered a brand new one in mass
not too long ago diascoria esculenta
and again dug into the statistics the
case that they made for it just simply
wasn't that strong
uh certainly not enough to to give it a
a really
um a really positive recommendation
to consumers um i will say that
the two biggest effects that were seen
that were kind of singled out
in this review paper the two biggest
effects
uh one supplement increased
uh testosterone by 151
nanograms per deciliter another
supplement
increased testosterone by 143 nanograms
per deciliter that this
was in uh male participants
male uh patients with infertility
so again it's a specialized population
here
no body comp measurements no performance
measurements nothing like that
and the thing about it is it's the two
biggest effects
that i saw in this review paper from the
same lab
published in the same journal using the
same dosage
but with different ingredients uh and
i i don't know what to make of that but
but i would definitely
hold off and wait for some independent
replication there that's what i call
reliability
that is it's keeping everything else
constant except for
the ingredient getting the same results
yeah
it's that's good stuff right not
necessarily
oh i'm sorry so there's a few things to
keep in mind with
with this particular body of literature
and
and this is transferable i mean this
this is
a series of things that you can
translate to a lot of different areas of
research but
we've talked about it on the show before
the first finders effect
the idea that usually the first big
flashy
paper that gets published on a topic a
lot of times
the findings are statistically
significant and the
effect size tends to be a lot bigger
than what we generally see
in the following work that comes out
later you know it's usually a really
eye-catching result
doesn't mean that anybody's at fault
doesn't mean anybody did anything wrong
but
a lot of times it's that first big paper
where they've really stacked the deck in
terms of methodology to find a big
effect size
and it usually gets a lot of attention
and if people have tried to study that
before
and gotten all results it's very
possible that they just didn't even
bother to publish it
so publication bias is another important
factor to keep in mind
because listen the idea that something
doesn't increase testosterone
is not exciting there's a lot of things
that don't increase testosterone in fact
most things don't increase testosterone
so if you're studying some obscure herb
that no one's ever looked at
and you say i think it's going to
increase testosterone and you you know
do a really small study not too much
time not too much money
and you find oh here's one more thing
that doesn't increase testosterone
you might not spend the months and
months and months trying to get that
published
and so that's why we can find these
bodies of literature where the first
study or two or three
might give us some optimism and then
study
four or five and beyond comes out and
the effect size goes from
you know oh this is going to increase
your test by 151 nanograms per deciliter
and all of a sudden it's down to like
maybe you'll get 10 if we average it out
another thing to keep in mind is
regional homogeneity and this is
something that
i've seen this with a number of
different bodies of literature spanning
several different continents so it's not
unique to any one country or anything
like that but
every now and then you will see some
ingredient some
food product some herb that has a lot of
significance to a particular country or
a particular region
whether that significance is economic or
cultural or both
and so i have seen meta-analyses that
actually separate
findings for a particular ingredient by
country
and they're like oh well the place where
this is grown it seems to work really
well
in all other places it doesn't seem to
work very well so
uh certainly not calling out any
individual country because i've seen it
with many
countries you know this is just kind of
a thing that happens
and it's it's no different than when we
look at uh
industry funding you know when we look
at you know a series of
a body of literature a series of papers
and we say oh you know hey when that
particular interest group funds it it
sure seems to work out pretty well
when everyone else funds the research it
doesn't work out well
so it's something to keep in mind when
you see that
you know every positive study comes from
one specific
place and all the other studies from all
the other places are
null or negative then that's something
that has to be kept in mind
another thing is if all the positive
findings are in the same journal
you see that a lot there's some journals
that kind of
have their hobby horse topic and like we
we just talked about with the
we talked about that with the
myers-briggs journal our last episode
yeah there's that one um there was one
nutrition journal i'm not going to call
it out by name mostly because i forget
the name
but it was very obvious for a while
there
that if you had a paper that looked good
for low-carb high-fat diets they'd take
it
period like there was this one journal
where all those papers were going
without fail and so uh it just happens
with journals sometimes
and you have to look at the journal and
be like why is this the only journal
where these things are considered
science
yeah i remember which journal that was
but if if you're not going to call it
out i'm not going to yeah
you know the one i'm talking about you
know you know which one it is you didn't
[ __ ] forget
i think i know but i i'm 97
confident
yeah but it's you know me i'm i'm a kind
person i'm not looking for all the smoke
as the kids say um but yeah
this stuff happens journals get like a
hobby horse topic that they really like
to
present favorably for some reason yeah
uh well
i think a lot of it has to do with the
power that editors and chiefs
have like absolutely and and eics are
humans just like everyone else and
people have their
their hobby horses their biases and you
know if if the editor of a journal just
decides
they really like a particular concept a
particular compound
uh you know they they may just be a
little bit less critical of it
than they would be for for other things
and that's
uh you know that's an unfortunate
outcome of
you know science being driven by people
who aren't perfectly objective but i
mean
no one's perfectly objective so that's
that's always going to happen
yeah and so when you when you're looking
at a body of evidence
you know if you were to ask me what what
are you looking for
when you say oh that that is robust
evidence that i feel good about
making conclusions from what you want to
see
is first of all plenty of studies for a
lot of these studies or for a lot of
these ingredients there's just not much
there
i mean this is a very sparse body of
literature
where you've got like a couple papers
for each uh
for each ingredient and like essentially
almost none of them measure what
these things are being marketed for like
you're not getting a lot of performance
or body comp outcomes here it's like
testosterone and spermatogenesis
like you know so you want to look at a
body of evidence with
plenty of studies from plenty of
different researchers
in plenty of different regions who all
are
approximate approximately finding
similar things
for this ingredient and of course you
expect that there's going to be sampling
error
and ideally the outcome of interest yes
that that was the other thing i intended
to mention
okay sorry no i i forgot uh but but i i
meant to yeah
i retract my apology yeah but but no you
want to see
are they measuring the thing i'm
interested in are they affecting it to a
practically
meaningful degree and is this a finding
that is reliable
is it happening regardless of whose lab
it's occurring in
regard you know region to region lab to
lab across the board
we we should be able to see if this
thing works if it's going to work for me
it should be able to work in a variety
of different scenarios and settings
and so that's what we're looking for and
i'll admit when it comes to supplements
i think that i tend to be a bit of a
skeptic
i tend to be a little bit slow to
embrace them
uh generally speaking i know sometimes
people have accused me of the opposite
which is
i find interesting but um
these are very toxic accusations being
thrown at me it's hard to be me greg
but but i i tend to say
i tend to be a late adopter that's
that's the way helms put it in one of
his articles in masses like
i i think a supplement manufacturer or a
supplement market or someone who's
selling the finished product
as a consumer i do think they owe me a
little bit of reassurance you know
fund a couple studies show me it works
and then i'll buy your stuff i i think
that's a pretty fair trade-off that's
the way i view it
and that's usually how my
recommendations kind of follow
now i mentioned that we would get to the
practical uh practical
application side of things or dealing
with practically significant outcomes so
even if you were to take a really really
enthusiastically
optimistic view of this literature this
very limited literature for all these
additional
ingredients you know most of these
studies are finding increases of if
there's an increase at all
50 maybe a hundred nanograms per
deciliter
and so i think a lot of times people
think in their mind
any increase in testosterone it's like
any press is good press
they're like if i can increase my
testosterone by eight
i'll take it and that just doesn't seem
to be the case when it comes to
performance and body composition this is
something that came up
in our articles about p ratios because a
lot of people are saying well
you know if you have excess adiposity
testosterone goes down that's going to
hurt your ability to make gains
but the amount that we need to move that
needle
for testosterone levels to really
tangibly
materially impact hypertrophy and
strength gains
we got to change it a lot it we're not
talking about
increasing my my test by 10 nanograms
per deciliter so
you know the classic papers were by
basin
and colleagues his 2001 paper i was
curious
you know he kind of established that
dose response relationship with
testosterone
and i was curious i looked back at you
know what kind of separation between
groups did they really induce
with that exogenous testosterone and you
know starting the study everybody was
around
you know from 550 to 650 that was kind
of everybody's baseline number
uh but man that the gaps between groups
in that study were like
sometimes as high as 400 sometimes as
high as a thousand
nanograms per deciliter difference in
blood testosterone
between these groups and so uh
yeah i mean
does testosterone matter it does but but
we need some
pretty big changes in testosterone
to to actually yield practically
meaningful differences with regards to
our ability
to get stronger and put on muscle so
i i really don't anticipate
that we're gonna stumble upon too many
herbal ingredients that are gonna give
us
a magnitude of change in testosterone
that is really going to move the needle
in terms of our ability to make gains
now if you're going from
a hypogonadal condition and you're
working with an endocrinologist
and with whatever intervention you're on
you go from well below the normal range
to squarely in the middle range
i i think that's going to do something
for you if you're
you know if you've got a normal in the
normal range of testosterone pretty
average level
and you decide decide to take a ton of
exogenous testosterone
that's definitely going to do something
for you we've seen that
quite a few times in high level sport
but these little changes within the
normal range
i'm just super skeptical that you're
going to get big return on your
investment there
now there used to be some stuff that was
very interesting on the market
uh greg you remember the good old days
uh oh hell yeah
i i never used them because they scared
the hell out of me
uh but back in the day there were all
these pro hormones
they were marketed as pro hormones uh
and you could go in the supplement store
they were just sitting on the shelf
you know and any kid could walk in there
and grab them
and like they were just designer
steroids i mean these these were oral
anabolics
that were masquerading as pro hormones
and they were all over the supplement
market in the
like er i would say like the
from probably like late 2000s to the
early and mid
2010s were they there that late
so in december 2014 that's when
in the united states congress uh passed
the designer anabolic steroid control
act
that was the act that really put the
nail on the coffin
they did some actions before that like
the fda and stuff
so i it was on its way down before they
really put the nail in the coffin i
think
but you know 2005 to
to you know until the time that they
really killed it in 2014
that that's what my memory gives me i
thought it was 2004.
oh no no 2014 it was when they really
tightened up
they tried to put something through
earlier and it just didn't work
yeah i just googled when we're pro
hormones banned
yeah and it says 2004 the anabolic
steroid control act
made it illegal for supplements to
contain anabolic steroids or pro
hormones
etc etc so there were just like still
loopholes in that so
the the one in 2014 was called the
designer anabolic steroid control act
so i think that i think that those
different pro hormones were finding
enough loopholes that they're like
okay fine then we're gonna expand this
yeah it was probably something where
like the 2004 one just said like
yeah we're banning steroids and pro
hormones here is a list of steroids and
pro hormones we're banning
and people are like oh well let's tweak
these a little bit so they slide through
and in 2014 they were just like yeah
and all similar ones too yeah i i think
that's what happened
but if rick collins is listening he's
probably going to be like you dumbasses
you don't know anything yeah i mean that
that that would make sense
yeah but uh but yeah so those things
were on the market and those were
they they were truly dude
it wasn't okay there was there was a lot
of young kids that were taking them and
like
didn't realize that they were just like
very hepatotoxic so i i'm glad that
those are
i'm glad that those are off the market
but uh
yeah so those might have done something
but you know
tribulus it's just not going to do it at
least
not based on any of the evidence that
i've seen and not outside of bulgaria
correct uh so then the question is you
know someone who
is interested in supporting uh
you know their natural endogenous
testosterone production keeping it
within the normal range what can you
actually do
um you know there is some truth to to
the idea of
avoiding excess adiposity uh you know
there is
a reduction in testosterone levels when
body fat starts to get
really really high you know there is a
relationship there
as we discussed in the p ratio
discussion
um it's you're probably not going to be
able to moderate
or modulate your adiposity to
specifically boost hypertrophy it's just
a magnitude thing but
you know if someone were to say if i
want to just hedge my bets and do my
best to keep testing the normal level
not specifically for hypertrophy but for
all those other things i mentioned
right so all the stuff that can be
associated with
a hypogonadal condition avoiding excess
adiposity would be a good idea
other things you could do of course
sleeping well
is going to be a good way to support
keeping your testosterone
uh you know within a normal range
exercising but avoiding
extended periods of really severe over
training
managing stress to the best of your
ability avoiding
extremely low energy availability
avoiding extremely low
fat intakes avoiding extremely high
intakes of phytoestrogens
we've seen studies given people up to
like 80 grams of soy protein a day
no problem in terms of androgen and
estrogen
signaling but there are some case
studies of
very very very high phytoestrogen intake
that would cause you to say well let's
just keep it in a
reasonable range there you want to avoid
regular consumption of really high
alcohol doses
and of course you want to avoid
micronutrient deficiencies uh some key
ones that that come to mind
things like boron zinc magnesium vitamin
d you want to make sure you're getting
plenty of them
uh and that's pretty much it and if
you're doing those things and you you
have some of those symptoms of being
hypogenatal you think you might have low
testosterone
you want to do something about it at
that point
you talk to a physician you go you go
get some blood work done
and uh you you know your physician will
take care of you
maybe they refer you to an
endocrinologist but you know
do do the normal medicine stuff
sometimes it's good you know just do
medicine
that's fine makes sense to me all right
so
i think you have a coach's corner
segment is that correct i do i do
uh so i want to talk about sticking
points a little bit and just
how to think about them i suppose so one
of the places where i think people
uh tend to go wrong tend to go astray
when they're thinking about their
sticking points is they might look at
video
and say like oh man i see where i
consistently miss lifts if i end up
missing them
and on lifts that are big grinders i see
where the bar is moving
the slowest and then you just use a
little bit of logic and you're like okay
when something's easy you move it fast
when when it's hard you move it slow
therefore the point that you're moving
at slowest is probably the hardest point
in the lift right
i think that's a pretty natural
chain of logic that people often follow
and so as a result
a lot of training ideas around um
you know training sticking points trying
to get stronger through a sticking point
uh is to target those ranges of motion
so
you know a typical sticking point or a
typical point of minimum
velocity or a typical point where you
might miss a lift that you do end up
missing
and the squat might be a little bit
above parallel for bench press it might
be
you know three four inches off the chest
and so you might look at that and say
like okay
what am i gonna do i'm going to do maybe
paul squats slightly above parallel or
like slightly high
box squats or something like that for
bench press maybe a low board press like
a one board press a two board press
really to build string through that
range of motion where the bar is moving
the slowest or where you
would typically miss a lift um
and you know uh i used to think that way
as well that's
that's definitely a logical thought
process but that is not actually your
weakest point in the lift
so to think about this uh i think it
makes the most sense to just think about
it from
like a basic physics perspective so we
know that force
is mass times acceleration uh your body
mass
is the same all the way through a lift
the weight on the bar
is the same all the way through the lift
unless you're using accommodating
resistance but we're just talking about
straight weight for now
so you can just forget about the mass
part
and just look at acceleration and so
when you look at a trace of
velocity with respect to position or
velocity with respect to time
for a lift that's a big grinder what you
see is right when you move the bar
say out of the hole on the squat or off
your chest on bench you see
uh an uptick in velocity the bar was not
moving in the positive direction and now
it is moving in the positive direction
and then velocity starts dropping off
pretty rapidly
it eventually gets very very slow
approaching zero velocity that is
you know the range where bar velocity is
at its slowest
and then once you break through that
sticking region the bar starts
accelerating
again velocity starts going up and then
eventually it drops back to zero
as you're approaching lockout and so
acceleration is change in velocity
and so when velocity is going down
acceleration is negative
and that means force output is lower
because again forces mass times
acceleration
and so as a result if you're interested
in how much force you're exerting
on the bar you shouldn't be looking at
bar speed you should be looking at
changes in bar speed and so where that
bar is decelerating
that's actually where you're putting the
least amount of force into the bar
and that is basically
right at the very bottom of the lift so
if you uh if you do have access to say a
linear position transducer and you you
can look to see
what that uh velocity with respect to
time
graph looks like you know a quarter of a
second
after you start the concentric you've
hit that first peak velocity and you
start decelerating so
you know rather than the weakest point
in your squat being right above
parallel you know it's it's [ __ ] an
inch above
where you start your concentric uh and
for bench press you know instead of it
being like
three four inches off the chest it's
like half an inch off your chest like
you get the bar moving and it starts
decelerating
pretty quickly after that uh so
you know just based on actual force
output that's what's going on
your actual weakest point in the lift is
actually quite a bit before
the point of of minimum bar velocity
and in fact it's probably even earlier
than that
um so one thing
going on really for all of your lifts
except for deadlift really
so squat bench press anything that
starts with an eccentric phase
you're going to have some degree of the
stretch shortening cycle kicking in
there's a lot of things that go into the
stretch shortening cycle there's
some degree of elastic recoil just from
elastin in your tendons
there's some central potentiation of
muscle activation and muscle contraction
due to the preceding eccentric
and also i think one of the most
important mechanisms of the stretch
shortening cycle that's talked about the
least
is an enhanced quote unquote active
state
and so what that is basically is as
you're reversing
the eccentric so you know as you're
decelerating as
say in the squat as you're nearing the
end of the eccentric and you're about to
uh reverse the lift and start standing
back up again
uh you're not having much change in
muscle length between
the very very end of the eccentric and
the very very start of the concentric
and so you can develop a lot of actin
myosin cross bridges in the muscle at
that time
you know during what's called the
amortization phase
and the more of those cross bridges you
develop the more
you can just you know kind of like shoot
out of the bottom like a spring pretty
much like you can develop
more cross bridges than you typically
would be able to during that time
so you put all of those things together
and during
you know even like a normal length
paul's bench press during
a squat without a super long pause
there's gonna be those
stretch shortening cycle related
mechanisms in play
uh so they're kind of i don't want to
say artificially giving you a boost
but they're allowing your muscles to
contract for
for a split second actually less than a
split second between like a quarter of a
second and half a second
uh for a very very brief period of time
allowing your muscles to contract harder
than they would otherwise be able to
when you look at studies that actually
look at isometric force output so
you know no preceding eccentric phase
you just get someone
and see how much force they can output
you know at the very bottom of a squat
five centimeters above that five
centimeters above that etc
they're the weakest at the very very
bottom uh without
the like the stretch shortening cycle is
why you have that initial little peak in
velocity in the first place
but when it just comes down to like raw
muscular horsepower
the very very bottom of the lift at
least in the case of squat and bench
press like that's
that's the weakest part so when it comes
to training sticking points
it doesn't make much sense to focus on
the range of motion that's a little bit
above that
you just want to train for strength at
the bottom and that that's what's going
to give you the most return on
investment
and i'll also note uh if you have those
standard sticking points like
standard places where you miss a little
bit out of the hole in the squat
uh two three inches off the chest for
bench that doesn't mean you have any
particular muscle weakness
you're just too weak like that's a
normal ass place to miss and that's
where you're gonna miss because that's
you know that's pretty soon after where
the lift is the hardest and the bar's
decelerating
uh so when you when you think about
training sticking points
in that context what you want to do is
just focus on the very bottom end of the
range of motion so
you know that could even be like
isometrics like uh you know for bench
press
set the pins to where the bars at at
chest height
put way more on the bar than you can
actually bench and just do isometrics
against it
same thing for for pin squats just you
know
load a bunch of weight on the bar try to
stand up against it you won't be able to
that's you know very highly specific
training
if you want to do some dynamic training
to train those parts of the range of
motion
you know instead of things like board
press or
slightly above parallel box squats it
would be things like
pin squats with the pin set at full
depth
or pin press with the pin set at chest
height
or even exercises that chan that train a
longer range of motion than you would
typically do so for example if you have
access to a
cambered bench bar sometimes called a
mcdonald bar
i think that's absolutely excellent
extended range of motion push-ups
similar type of concept lets you train
through a longer range of motion than
you would typically be able to for bench
for squat if you squat any style
for competition or just for your your
1rms that is
you know specifically engineered to let
you hit
the required depth but not go deeper if
there is a technique that lets you go
even deeper than that
that would probably be beneficial for
training your weak point in the squat
which
you know would be slightly higher than
that extended range of motion
technique would allow you to squat so i
i think
things like that are are really your
best bet for
training your sticking point which again
isn't the slowest point in the lift
it's the very bottom of the lift uh the
place i think that's
different is the conventional deadlift
so
uh the reason the conventional deadlift
is different is
some people you know they they either
break the bar off the floor and lock it
out or they uh don't
most people however can break the bar
off the floor
on a lift they end up missing but still
miss at some point below their knee
and a conventional deadlift is not
preceded by
an eccentric you shouldn't have much
stretch shortening cycle
at all going on like maybe you get a
little bit if you
like really try to get tight and pull
yourself down to the bar but it's not
it's not going to be the same as like a
full eccentric um so i
i do legitimately think that you are a
little bit weaker
maybe two three inches off the floor on
the deadlift than you are
at floor height again if you have that
sticking point that's
shin height below the knee uh so if if
that's you
uh i do actually think slightly reducing
range of motion
might be uh a way to train your sticking
point so you know
probably like the lowest um
uh what do you call it
i have it in my notes block pulls yeah
man my brain's not working today
like the lowest block pulls you can
manage so for
uh for me i i have uh
like i'll just do block pulls on like a
25 pound
bumper plate or like a 45 pound bumper
plate so you know that's
elevated off the ground an inch and a
half two inches up to about four inches
i find for me that that is harder than
dead lifting from the floor
uh which is an indication it's doing
what it's supposed to do
and honestly i think that's one of that
should be your first tip off that like
slightly high box squats and like two
board press might not be the best way to
train your sticking point
most people have experience with two
board press can two board press more
than they can bench their chest
uh which which should suggest that
two board press height is not your
weakest point you know
um but yeah so so i i do think with
conventional deadlift
um that style of thinking is
perhaps beneficial where you know maybe
like a very very low block pull
uh is a good way to go about training
that sticking point and maybe you're not
actually your weakest at the floor uh
but yeah
for the most part squat bench sumo
deadlift
your weakest at the very bottom of the
lift train that like that
that's your sticking point that's where
your weakest
sounds good to me now greg
did you have any specific q a questions
that you
absolutely need to answer this week i
know you want it to be gone by five
which is one minute from now
uh you know what you know what we could
do a really quick
q a episode at some other point just you
know 45 minutes an hour
in and out yeah yeah i think we can hold
off on it
let's let's just do that and wrap up now
all right well to play us out we've got
two things and don't worry
i don't have to be out at exactly five
we'll be okay
um to play us out i've got a quick shout
out to a great company i learned about
today
i know you've got something as well so
man i was absolutely tickled by this i
was you know just reading around
uh reviewing some literature i was
looking at a particular study involving
beta ectisterone which is a phytosteroid
and you know as a good research reader
of course i'm reading the methods i'm
not just jumping down to the conclusions
and in the methods a paper is going to
describe the materials they used
and where those materials were obtained
from
and so one of the concepts we've talked
about
many times on the podcast is the dreamer
bulk
and for those who are just jumping in uh
in season four here a dreamer bulk it
gets its name from someone back on the
bodybuilding forums
whose username was dreamer or some
something related to dreamer and
you know he endeavored to gain a great
deal of muscle he said i'm going for it
i'm going to eat a ton i'm going to lift
i'm going to get huge
and it was a bit of a bit of an
unfortunate attempt
at at building a lot of muscle um you
know i don't want to pick on this
individual but it just became a funny
concept the idea of the dreamer bulk was
i'm just going to eat everything in
sight and lift and trust that i'm going
to gain all
muscle no fat and and that usually isn't
going to be the case
and in his progress pictures he took
them
with very unfortunate lighting at a very
unfortunate angle
and again i don't want to poke fun at
the individual but
some of the later progress pictures did
resemble the concept of him maybe
morphing into a frog is that a
diplomatic way to say it
yeah i think that's pretty fair uh and
so
you know it's not like i made that up it
was an intuitive enough conclusion that
people started talking
on the bodybuilding forums about this
imaginary supplement called
frogtech uh this was back when cell tech
was the funny thing you'd say about
celtec was saying that you'd gain like a
billion pounds of muscle
any supplement making outrageous claims
people would say oh you must be on cell
tech or something
uh if you made a lot of gains so they
they started talking about this thing
frog tech that would you know
essentially give you great gains and i
guess make you look a little bit more
like a frog
and uh so i'm reading this ectisterone
paper today
and i'm like oh where did they get their
product from well it was 95
purity manufa manufactured by no other
than a company called frogtech located
in russia
so there is a legitimate frog tech
supplement out there for anyone who
wants to get that as
really just a memento i think just as a
keepsake for anyone who was involved
on the forums back in the day eric i
have a question for you
sure did you look up uh frogtext social
media
fingerprint i did not uh so they have
an instagram account that i've come
across
i'm pretty sure it's the real thing the
in in it they link to the website
frogtech.ru
okay uh in the instagram account if you
want to look for it is just frog
underscore tech
you know it it has the the handle so i i
think this is real um
this is one of the one of the weirder
uh supplement instagram accounts i've
ever come across
so it's it's pictures of supplement
bottles very normal
okay uh pictures of pretty jacked
looking people
uh standing with frog tech products in
hand
that's pretty normal uh a lot of pepe
memes
oh like this is not a frog tech from
bodybuilding fromthebodybuilding.com
forums type tribute
oh doesn't that have like very
regrettable connotations
yeah so this is a uh a pepe
themed supplement company oh boy and
uh there's just straight up porn on
their instagram account
what yeah uh there are
several pictures of women
who are wearing like
you know like bikini bottoms but then
their upper body it's just body paint
oh wow um so well this turned from a
very
uh funny coincidence to a very
regrettable segment
it's still funny it's just funny in a
different way i i
you just can't have nice things anymore
i i saw some funny
oh frog tech that was a thing people
used to joke about who knew it was real
and and it's been ruined you i found one
very light-hearted funny thing and you
you
launch an asteroid right at it i
i think that a pepe branded supplement
company is very funny
okay whatever you say i'm i'm scared to
death at this because i know that
there's negative connotations associated
with that
but as you know greg i don't participate
in society
i don't know what any of it's about so i
have no idea what world i'm venturing
into here
and frankly i don't want to know my
world's fine
i wake up i sit by the pond and i read
and then i come over here and i write
fair enough so if you want to buy
frogtech supplements just enter
the code sbs pod check no
that is a complete joke uh okay so so my
to play is helping i actually have two
things uh the first
is uh gonna talk about my meal prep for
this last week
because i'm very tickled with it it's
very very good
uh it's it's basically like just a kind
of quiche-esque
breakfast casserole that is delicious
uh so i have a very very large baking
dish
uh it's like 11 by 17 by four
and this took up every every possible
square inch of that
so very very voluminous it was 36 eggs
a quart of two percent milk uh about
three pounds of diced ham
nine pounds of potatoes and two pounds
of reduced fat
cheddar cheese and uh like three pretty
large onions
um so you know just uh cubed up the
and parboiled the potatoes uh so cubed
into
about half inch cubic cubes
uh par boiled them until they were
just about but not quite done drained
them
let them cool and then beat the eggs
beat the milk in poured that over the
potatoes
stirred in the ham stirred in the cheese
finely dice
the onion stirred that in just bake at
300 degrees
until uh it's pretty set but the st the
center is still
a little jiggly uh and if you want to
temp it
the thermometer should register at least
like 165
170 that's around the point that the
eggs will be
will be set up enough uh and then
you just cut it and serve it and it's
it's so good um
i think per serving it's like 49 grams
of protein
44 grams of carbs like 24-25 grams of
fat
uh and it's just everything one would
hope
breakfast would be uh the
the middle pieces are just
exactly what you're going for with a
custard so it's set but still
super creamy very delicious uh
this this is definitely one of my
favorite recent meal preps
nice now you've also got a link here i
know you're probably trying to be
conscious of time but
i i can't i can't resist the link just
says
where do eels come from yeah what could
that possibly mean that's exactly what
it is
so so shout outs to my wife uh lindsay
she recently read this article and sent
it my way it's called
where do eels come from it's from the
new yorker magazine
from may of last year and the title's
self-explanatory
uh it is about eel reproduction
and how it is still a complete mystery
um
so so yeah yeah scientists know
where baby eels originate uh
at least like european eels they come
from the sargasso sea
um and they know that eels go through
like
several life life stages so like they
start as like basically
little like larva type things drift
along the tides to europe
and then they become like brown eels
that just like
hang out in like ponds and streams and
whatnot
and then eventually they turn silver
and they're they go back into the ocean
presumably to reproduce and somehow
their eggs and larvae wind up in the
sargasso sea
but the adult eels have never been seen
in the sargasso sea before
no one knows how the [ __ ] they reproduce
um
turns out sigmund freud makes uh
makes an appearance in this article
apparently as a young man he was
obsessed not with human genitals but
with eel genitals
he would just buy hundreds of pounds of
eels and dissect them
and just try to find the gonads and he
could not find the gonads he's like how
the [ __ ] do these things reproduce
turns out we still don't really know how
eels reproduce
um have we not are there any eels in
captivity
they don't reproduce in captivity so we
have no idea
um there was oh man so
there was a great quote from the german
biologist matt
schultz uh and this was from back before
like quantum mechanics was discovered
and people started
like really getting an idea of just how
weird
reality is uh you know this was before
like dna was discovered etc
like back when people were way
overconfident during the
the modernist era uh so the german
biologist max schultz
on his deathbed uh this is a quote uh
lying on his deathbed observed
perhaps wistfully that he was leaving
the world where quote
all the important questions had now been
settled all of them that is
except for the eel question so you know
back during the 1800s
uh that was the last great mystery of
the universe
the they did not have an answer to the
eel question
and we still don't have an answer to the
eel question and i had
no [ __ ] idea and this was a really
really cool article that we will link in
the show notes and i hope you enjoy it
as much as i did
i'm gonna criticize freud here a little
bit i feel like if you were
dissecting any being
looking for the reproductive organs
wouldn't you think after like two or
three tries like this just isn't for me
like i'm not going to be able to do this
i don't
i don't know why you'd have to try that
many times freud was really into
genitals
like yeah just i mean that's the brand
right yeah i mean
he he he was on his [ __ ] from a
young age
yeah yeah that's weird uh i can't
believe that uh
i if you would have asked me if there
were
any animal that i could name like that i
know of
that we had not figured out how it how
it reproduces i wouldn't have thought
one exists
it's absolutely amazing it is the eel
um well hey ended the show on a great
note
um all right so thanks for listening as
always
we will be back soon with another
episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you